you did a film Boogie Nights that people
absolutely loved and I'm told that you
turned down the offer to do that movie
seven times that's true I I have a hard
time with that whole better use another
adjective I have a difficult time
looking it just wasn't my kind of film
right right so the subject matter of
making pornographic films very
uncomfortable it did it made me very
uncomfortable yeah because I was afraid
they might recognize me is this true
that you so we were even after shooting
the movie I'm told that you were so
uncomfortable making the movie that
after the movie was done before he would
even seen it you wanted to hit the
director Paul Thomas Anderson you wanted
to hit him in the face
no I don't want to hit him in the face I
just wanted to hit him I don't think you
liked me really he had such a I mean you
had gave such a brilliant performance in
that film then yeah you really did and
perfect for that role I heard at the
time that you didn't even want to see
yourself in Boogie Nights have you seen
it yet have you know haven't you haven't
watched it no I don't want to see it
it's fantastic come on you could come to
my place we could watch Boogie Nights
Oh Oh God might do that okay all right
I screen it regularly
you